>> Hey Suzanne, do you want to play this mind game thing again?
>> Sure.
Yes.
>> Haim is the bus driver who woke up this morning with a new journey in mind.
The first stop, there were three passengers who hopped on the bus and
the second stop there were two passengers who hopped on and one passenger hopped off.
And then the third stop,
there were two passengers who hopped on, and two passengers off.
And then the last stop there were three passengers who
hopped on and no passengers hopped off.
My question is, what's the bus driver's name?
Okay, let's see how a computer would have
remembered both the bus driver's name and all these numbers at the same time.